oh
that's it's that time again it is time
for another very exciting edition of
Market takes I'm your host Dion Robert
Bowen I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me and I thank you for that look we
are diving in today uh to the November
non-farm payrolls report the the jobs
report for you plebs out there
um and this was a very interesting
report we've seen a significant Market
reaction we're looking at the stock
market the Futures Market s p NASDAQ Dao
Futures all moving pretty significantly
after the release of this report we're
going to get into all that tell you what
the moves mean and why also looking
around markets I'm looking at uh you
know dollar currency Market we're seeing
Bond markets move in some very
interesting ways it's not quite one
linear move but we're going to break
down all of that as well as get into
just what the report says uh talk about
what some of the most important numbers
are maybe some of the things that you're
not seeing in those headlines out there
we're going to be talking about all all
that so thank you very much for being
with us here on Market takes so look
we're going to talk about what the
headline numbers were obviously how many
jobs the US economy added last month as
well as the unemployment percentage or
the unemployment rate we're going to
talk about how those numbers compared to
expectations because we know these
numbers aren't just in a vacuum
everything is all about expectations and
most importantly how these impacted the
Federal Reserves expectations knows of
fed share Jerome Powell we're going to
talk about some of the most important
numbers in this report like I said and
how those relate to recession fears
and inflation expectations what we can
discern looking forward for the future
of inflation and what we expect the FED
to take from this report about inflation
uh of course like I said we're also
going to talk about how the markets
reacted and we're going to talk about
what to look for going forward I'm going
to tell you all that so look no more
talking you know just about air we're
going to get into the numbers I know
that's why you're here because you all
love the numbers the headline numbers
the U.S economy added 263 000 jobs in
November the unemployment rate unchanged
at 3.7 percent unemployment rate has
really been in that range of 3.5 percent
to 3.7 percent most of the year so not a
big move there and again this month
really unchanged from the previous month
now that 263 000 jobs is more than
expected
and we're showing that not only are the
job gains not slowing as we've seen this
consistent slowing pattern for most of
the Year we're actually picking back up
and so that could be one reason that
we're seeing the market reaction that we
are this morning now a key piece of data
was just that again we'd seen that Trend
cooling you'd seen declining job numbers
really since uh since July this was the
first time that job that we actually saw
an increase in number of jobs from the
previous month and that's that's that's
not a sign that the FED wants to see or
at least it's the market is interpreting
it as not something the FED wants to see
um that's something that I think is why
you're seeing stock prices down right
now bond yields up but again we'll get
into all that in just a minute so the
expectation was for 200 000 jobs we got
263 000 jobs so not a huge uh overshot
in terms of the the number but like I
said we're moving back towards that 300
000 number and actually when you look at
the trend
um you're seeing now 282 000 jobs as the
three month average that is well above
the average that we saw in 2019 when you
want to go back pre-pandemic back in
2019 we still had a strong economy when
when folks were adding jobs consistently
it was only 164 000 three-month average
at the end of the year so we're well
above that pace by more than a hundred
thousand more jobs added and again when
it comes to the Federal Reserve trying
to slow the economy down and saying okay
we can't stop raising rates we can't
stop choking off and making the economy
tight until we see these things slow
down that's not positive for markets
certainly a good thing for the economy
certainly a good thing for job Seekers
out there folks trying to get a raise
folks trying to get a job but for the
Federal Reserve this is not a great
report and for the market well if you're
a stock investor and you're long the
market this is not a great report for
you
um I want to talk really quickly about
the jolts reports job openings and labor
turnover survey uh that we had come out
just earlier this week or last week
um that showed that there were still
10.3 million job openings in October
that's down from 10.7 million the month
before you still got 6 million hires in
October that's down 84 000 from
September 5.7 million separations that's
also down from September but the
difference between hires and separations
was about 329 000 all that means the
only reason I'm telling you that is that
was well above the 260 000 jobs added
from the non-farm payrolls report so we
we saw in October joltz report said more
jobs were added than the payrolls report
sowed then we get this month more jobs
added than expected and what that
contributes to is a sense that okay the
job market the hiring Market is not
slowing down as the Federal Reserve has
said they'd like to see remember this
isn't just conjecture Fed chair Jerome
Powell was out here just this week
saying you know what too many job
openings job growth moving too fast
wages Rising too high these are things
that we need to see come down and cool
off before we can stop doing what we're
doing which is Raising interest rates
and choking off the economy so that's
why you're seeing I think a negative
reaction from the markets also important
to note the quit rate fell in October so
you're seeing less people quitting more
people hiring and that's not a sign for
inflation slowing down because as less
people quit well you got more
competition for these jobs that means
employers have to raise the rates that
they pay means more people get raises
means more money flowing through the
economy more spending going on that's
generally a good thing for the economy
but not when you've got inflation near
40-year highs and that's what this is
all about so the FED has said very
clearly we are watching this joltz
number we are watching the jobs Market
because that's going to give us a sign
that inflation is Cooling and we're not
seeing the job market cool down still
saying 1.7 job openings for every
unemployed person from the jail from the
jolts report and Fed chair Jerome Powell
mentioned that very specifically in his
Brookings uh Speech just this week on
Wednesday so definitely keep that in
mind the markets are responding to Fed
talk because the FED is really the only
thing that matters look if you're not
watching inflation and you're not
watching the fed you shouldn't even be
in the market right now you shouldn't be
in investing close your account you know
go go look for Pokemon
um this is really the trade right now
and so everything is all about what the
FED is doing and what they're saying and
speaking to the market and how the
market interprets this data in terms of
what the Federal Reserve is going to do
next so looking back at the trend the
trend has been jobs lower consistently
each month we had 687 or 678 000 jobs
added in February and we've kind of seen
a consistent downward Trend since then
in July you saw that last time the jobs
report really picked back up and then
we've been kind of consistently moving
down since then we have bucked that
Trend now and the worry is that we are
going to keep moving back up higher
adding too many jobs which some how is
bad for the stock market like I said
like I just explained look probably the
most important number in this report
that maybe isn't getting a lot of play
in those headlines is average hourly
earnings the month over month number
Rose by 0.6 percent that doesn't sound
like a lot but that is double the
expectations economists had expected
average hour earnings to pick up by 0.3
percent and we got an additional 0.6
percent pick up in average hourly
earnings the year-over-year number is
still about 5.1 percent that hasn't
moved too much but it was kind of
declining towards that four percent
number now picking back up towards five
percent and that means again as average
hourly earnings rise more people have
more money they're spending uh you know
the FED isn't able to choke off the
economy as effectively if people
continue to have money that they can go
out and spend keep buying companies keep
raising those prices Americans still
able to pay it what the FED wants is to
beat the economy down and make it so
folks to say hey you know what I'm not
going to go out and spend I'm not going
to borrow money to pay for these things
I'm not going gonna try to expand my
business I just want to sit tight and
you know not expand the economy by going
out and doing what I do that is not what
we're seeing from this report
um so as we look out at the overall
environment we're looking at the market
this report has likely cooled off some
inflation expectations and the idea that
inflation expectations had been falling
consistently we're likely to see a
cooldown of that and maybe see inflation
expectations kind of hold Pat they've
been you know investors if you look at
the 10-year the five year those Break
Even inflation rates which show what
investors are betting on for the economy
we have seen kind of a a consistent come
down but not a you know a drop off the
cliff we haven't seen inflation
expectations move meaningfully back
toward the fed's two percent Target and
that's what the Federal Reserve wants
they want inflation expectations
anchored meaning held down right around
that two percent we're seeing five-year
inflation expectations up closer to two
and a half percent about 2.45 as of
yesterday and even 10-year inflation
expectations right around 2.4 percent
not high it's not much higher than two
percent but it's significantly High if
you look at the Historical long-term
average so that again is is what the
market is saying it's seeing these
numbers and saying hey you know what we
don't think the Federal Reserve is going
to be done they may have to hold rates
higher for longer raise higher than we
expected and that's going to do more
longer term damage to the economy and
like I said it's right now things are
good you're seeing hiring continue
you're seeing average hourly earnings
rise don't forget still below inflation
so real earnings are still negative
because we're well below the rate of
inflation but
the trend is not our friend when it
comes to those sorts of things so that
wage growth number 0.6 percent probably
the most important number in this report
like I said that a lot of folks really
aren't talking about right now
um look the other thing is that jobs
added number and one thing that an
economist pointed out this morning I
thought was very interesting was we're
seeing people especially here in the U.S
run through their excess savings you had
2.5 trillion dollars of excess savings
um raised through the pandemic kind of
at the start of this year now that level
may be down to about one trillion
dollars so and that's again overall
throughout the economy most of that is
at the higher wage levels those lower
wage earners those folks the bottom end
of the income Spectrum have a lot less
and a lot of them are expected to be
getting pushed back into the workforce
but here's the other very important
number from this report that maybe
you're not here and talked about in the
headlines labor force participation
declined again we saw labor forced
participation dropped to 62.1 percent it
has declined every month since August
you want that number picking up because
when there's more competition for jobs
you've got employers able to hire more
people be more selective they can have a
little bit more room to say ah you know
what you're not getting a five percent
wage giving you three percent wage
that's not great for workers it's not
great for you and I but it's what the
Federal Reserve wants because they need
to cool down inflation so this labor
force participation rate that broadly is
negative no matter what's happening when
it's going down we're seeing that
Decline and that could again contribute
to inflation picking up and again those
negative outcomes for the Federal
Reserve
so likely recession fears a little bit
cooled off by this because if people are
still adding folks to the work roles if
people are still adding folks to the job
roles excuse me it's hard to really have
a recession when lots of people have
jobs one thing that I've been talking
about with folks is you know could you
have a recession where you've still got
this under four percent unemployment
people still have their jobs they just
can't afford things because inflation is
so high that's one thing to keep your
eye on but as we think about the
traditional ideas of a recession this
jobs report certainly kind of pushes
that off back to the back burner so
we're going to check out wsj.com right
now talk about how markets are reacting
like I said the stock market stock
futures really sold off before the
market opened up and we had this report
out at 8 30 this morning you saw the Dow
really just jump off a cliff the NASDAQ
the S P 500 all lower by significant
numbers and we are still seeing markets
now that the market is opened
uh we're still seeing the Dow the s p
the Nasdaq all down the S P 500 down by
a little more than one percent NASDAQ
down by about 1.3 percent so it'll be
interesting to see what happens
throughout the day because you saw a
significant decline precipitous decline
really right after the report came out
and then we kind of came back up and now
we've kind of come back down so
investors really trying to make up their
minds on how bearish is this for the
outlook for the stock market a really
interesting response you know I saw from
the bond market because bonds bond
yields really jumped up especially on
those longer dated yields 10 to 30 years
and then came right back down uh one
thing I want to talk about before I
forget
um the stock market has been on a tear
over the past two months the Dow
especially the Dow was up four percent
in November and up 20.4 percent in the
last two months that is the biggest
increase for the Dow Jones Industrial
Average since 1938. now the Dow is still
down by four percent year-to-date about
4.8 eight percent but with the strong
gains that we've been seeing on some of
this on some of the data and I'm going
to tell you about what data reports are
coming up over the next two weeks or so
that could again push this over we could
see the Dow go positive by the end of
the year which would be crazy given how
low we've been and especially crazy
given how low the NASDAQ still is the
NASDAQ was up 4.4 percent in November
but it's been down eight of the last 10
months it'll last 11 months excuse me
and is still down about 30 percent
year-to-date so the NASDAQ is down about
30 percent the Dow might end the year
positive that is a huge huge difference
and it's because those high-flying tech
companies are really just getting beaten
down by these fed interest rate hikes
the more it costs to borrow money the
more the market punishes those tech
companies that don't make a lot of
profit and even the ones that do because
again their their profits out into the
future are looking less Rosy when you've
got higher interest rates of the future
growth is something that investors
really they don't want to pay for they
want growth now they want companies that
turn profits now and a lot of those are
in the Dow and that's why you're seeing
this this Chasm really of difference
between the Dow and the NASDAQ um as it
comes to returns look as I talked about
bonds picked back up you saw a big jump
in the 10-year the 30 year kind of
across the board and now you've kind of
come back lower Market's really kind of
reversing a lot of that big sell-off
that you saw because maybe okay maybe
this isn't so bad maybe this doesn't
mean that inflation's going to pick back
up and continue growing you know 263 000
jobs added not that much higher than 200
000 still well below 300 000 still kind
of keeping with the trend of okay folks
are hiring but they're not hiring these
big 500 000 numbers things like that so
you saw one yields really tick up and
they are still up really when you look
across the across the board from the
three month all the way up to the
30-year Bond but we're seeing reversal
that watch that today because I'm
interesting to see what the bond market
makes of this report as we look out at
the currency Market the dollar had a
similar reaction you saw the value of
the dollar really Spike up after this
report and some of that is coming back
off investors starting to rethink how
much this really means for the fate of
growth or for the trajectory of growth
moving forward that's a big thing we saw
the crypto Market really holding steady
crypto's got its own issues right now
Bitcoin ethereum holding right about
flat ethereum up by about point four
percent but not a big move and as we
look at it Commodities crude Futures are
up by almost one percent uh we're seeing
gold down by almost one percent uh
silver down really natural gas down by
almost three percent definitely
something to watch but a lot of those
are idiosyncratic issues not moving a
lot based on this jobs report
um look we're going to get out of here
but I thank you again for joining us
here on Market takes really quickly
here's what you need to be looking out
for next because like I said the market
has has been wild over the past few
weeks and you're going to want to be
aware and alert for these next few
reports on Monday we've got U.S Services
PMI I don't talk a lot about the PMI
purchasing managers index but the pmis
lately have been absolutely awful this
week we got the lowest report on uh
services or I'm sorry U.S Manufacturing
Services PMI since 2020. we got another
bad report from Chicago the Midwest is
doing horribly the worst since 2020 back
in the pandemic days so you're gonna
have this big report on Monday U.S
Services PMI Global Services PMI and I
and the ism's report on Business
Services as well as the employment
trends index you're going to want to
watch for those on Monday that could be
a big Market Moving Day on Wednesday we
get U.S consumer credit that has been
extremely high all year I want to read
you a little quote here from Matthew
Schultz he is the chief credit analyst
for Lending Tree he says quote in normal
Economic Times we this would be a huge
jump we saw 25 5.3 billion dollars of
consumer credit added that would
normally be a huge jump however it is
actually the second smallest increase in
the past year Consumer Credit has been
huge there's been a lot of borrowing a
lot of people putting things on credit
rather than buying them out right that's
something you definitely need to watch
for Friday of course PPI the producer
price index that's big for inflation on
Tuesday the Consumer Price Index if we
get another low report you could see
markets really take off if you get a
higher than expected report you could
see a massive sell-off CPI is going to
be huge this week and then the very next
day on Wednesday we will be right here
on Market takes breaking down what we
hear from the Federal Reserve and fed
share Jerome Powell at their press
conference on Wednesday December 14th so
thank you very much for being with us
that's going to do it for us here on
Market takes we will be right here I'm
taking next week off I'm going on a
little vacation but we'll be right back
here on December 14th hope to see you
then uh right here on Market takes